hey everyone is the big story this week
with new details coming out about the
deleted and altered scenes in the final
cut of the film what were they why were
they changed we will explain now this is
the need to know a weekly deep dive into
all of the biggest news this week so
we're also gonna look at the new Star
Wars trilogy from Rian Johnson in the
live-action Star Wars series the Harry
Potter the Harry Potter a our game of
Avengers and x-men exist in the same
movies together and of course Justice
League news and more and all these
stories are based on the requests and
reactions that you guys sent us via
Stardust click our start us download
link in the description below so you can
upload your reactions to your favorite
movies and TV shows tag us at new rock
stars and get them featured on this show
by the way I am Erik Bosse and the rest
of these brave heroes with me at the
table are Oh Sam basher over here Phil
Molina my name is Maude Garrett
we are the panel well let's get started
with our top story guys Thor ragnaroks
deleted scenes now when you watch thor
ragnarok this week which i assume you
all did
then you may have noticed that some of
these scenes look different from the
footage that we saw in trailers and
promo material so let's break down the
major changes and by the way spoiler
alert for some of the plot details that
happened in the movie guys it's been
over a week but you click on this video
so you know watch it your own discretion
okay the most glaring of these changes
was the setting of hellas introduction
in the trailers remember hella appeared
to Thorin Loki in I in destroyed Mjolnir
and in new york city alleyway but the
location was changed to a cliffside
field in norway in the final cut of the
film also based on set photos taken of
anthony hopkins
odin was initially going to appear as a
homeless person in new york now the
reason this was changed according to
director Taika Waititi was that Odin
dying in these goofy clothes in New York
totally off like test audiences were
confused as to why Odin was like it
seems like a middle finger a little bit
well it's a little bit of a reference to
like what if God was one of us shows me
so maybe that's what he was going for
but either way test audiences just felt
like his death didn't have enough
wait so what tt reset the scene in
Norway the birthplace of course of North
Norse mythology he thought it had more
weight when he just became mist over
water spores similar to the appearance
of wind Rickett died in the previous
story movie she anticipated her spores
yeah no one it really does and that's
why it's cold nerd note effect no one
mister does one word that works well
anyway in a required hellas arrival
which has to happen immediately after
Odin's dead that it triggers her freedom
now to take place in this setting too
that's why this location was changed
anyway do you guys agree with this
change what do you think about this this
change I Taika Waititi tonally yeah that
makes sense like it was the set photo
was really fun to see the outcomes
having fun on set that makes me happy to
see these actors having a great time but
now when you think about it like also
I'm gonna be honest it looks cooler her
popping up in New York just like as a
visual but if it's to set up for Odin do
it in a place that means more if you
watch the movie the scene does feel
really weird and still kind of it
doesn't have the weight that it should
behind it but it the very least it's not
a joke that this person's dying so I
guess I kind of liked the change I just
don't think it's pretty cool I'm seeing
it a lot especially with the Star Wars
movies just how much you can change
after the trailer has come out yeah so I
think it's a kind of a cool thing that
they are able to make a huge difference
like that with this kind of reshoot
without it affecting the storyline or
effecting too much else it's just a few
more workdays for our professional cast
yeah a little more money yeah I don't
think that it's it did what they were
kind of hoping for words like to me this
this didn't wood didn't feel weight here
because it felt like I know a place like
in Calabasas I mean like it was just
grass it didn't actually the emotional
weight needed to come from Thor reacting
to his father's death that wasn't really
there something that's what they should
have changed the other thing is I'm
actually a little bummed that he
normally never doesn't make it it by the
way but happen line up so I I the the
time that Odin spent as a homeless
person was actually supposed to be the
answer of what happened since all of
these movies have passed away
Loki's pretending to be Odin and the
answer was given well Loki has like
placed Odin on earth and he's pretending
to be a homeless person or whatever it
was it was going to give us conclusion
to that arc and instead it was just kind
of like oh yeah he's just been like
hanging out in Calabasas it might be
something with like Anthony Hopkins is
such as well respected that's be an
actor and they didn't want to put him in
this kind of expression here is almost a
reflection of how goofy this scene kind
of felt it probably felt a bit more
comedic to see Odin pop up in these
clothes and I think my my only gripe
with it is like I think it's cool to
reset it in Norway yeah that is kind of
like even in the opening shots of the
first Thor movie it's this prologue
scene where they're talking about you
know an ancient Norway but for some
reason I don't know if that cliffside
where they shot it actually was Norway
it felt a little Jeanette like Norway is
known for having these like beautiful
landscapes these Geo porn shots and I
think maybe they could have picked a
better few word to shoot huh I don't
know I think they did do Calabasas yeah
[Music]
like taking dr. strange well the next
big change that you guys might have
noticed was that shot of the four person
revenge errs lineup you know Hulk Thor
Valkyrie and Loki on the Bifrost bridge
facing down hella that was in the
trailer it looks great it's not in the
final cut of the movie all these
characters were definitely part of this
battle but they were scattered across
different areas now it's possible this
group shot like mod was a might have
just been composed solely for the
trailer just shooting interesting
team-up shots for the trailer to show us
who's in the movie and whereas in the
final cut they can kind of use them as
they need to for the narrative but one
according to Taika Waititi one amazing
joke that he did shoot but he left out
of the movie said it might show up in
the blu-ray as a blu-ray extra was a
callback to The Avengers with a hulk and
loki standing side by side and then hulk
just punches loki right out of frame of
course
you know this would have been a callback
to the joke earlier in the movie where
Hulk thrashes Thor around the way he did
Loki in the Avengers I don't know I
would have liked to seen this yeah I bet
that deleted scene that ring cool I get
why they did this but like that's that's
totally fine but that joke would have
been pretty fun yeah little frustrating
when we keep seeing stuff that just not
in in the movie because the reason they
they're so effective at making it
excited about the movie is oh man I
can't wait to see the moment where they
all line up and face off against this
person that this visually implies that
hella is one person who's enough threat
for for like the greatest fighters like
yeah most powerful beings in this area
and it's like well when you don't have
that one faceoff moment you don't have
those peaks of excitement and Chris
McQuarrie who is a famous screenwriter
and so if he's worked a lot of Mission
Impossible movies he was recent time AHA
now because the marketing department
gets really mad at you if you don't have
these kinds of moments what they're
doing is that they're going out of their
way to shoot every single day one shot
that could be in the trailer whether or
not it's gonna be the movie they just
kind of go out of the way and like
alright now let's do something treilery
you stand over there you stand there
let's make it look cool great now we
give that to the trailer department and
we don't actually put that in the movie
yeah thus far that hasn't bugged me in
in movies I mean unless we like to look
at nope I can't actually pick him was
gonna say Suicide Squad but I don't want
even any attention no III honestly it
hasn't bugged me like a lot of people
got mad with spider-man homecoming when
there was that shot of Iron Man and
spider-man swinging together such a
trailer moment exactly and but when you
watch it you're like all the buildings
around them
spider-man's thing goes above all the
buildings like there's nothing that
lines it the shot does make any sense
like the shot is clearly made just to be
the end tag to say the release date is
clearly what it is spider-man is just
like students web to the sky using that
Star Wars trailer as the example for
raquan because a lot of this stuff in
the trailer didn't even make the movie
at all it didn't last the reshoots and I
think apparently a fan was so upset at
this that they tried to sue Disney for
Sep for what is it like misinformation
or like they did that for a drive to
they got one we got mad cuz she's like
oh it's like fast and furious is like no
right or nothing yeah drive is nothing
like can we meet this woman bring on the
show woman
so I wanted fast and furious it's wrong
gobbling if she has a PhD I think yeah
it might just be because these movies
are to a degree fanservice so like these
kind of trailer moments and these
team-up shots are kind of why people are
going to see movies so if it's not in
the movie they might feel a little yeah
but famous we didn't wrap around the
legal side of it is they're not doing
anything wrong like it apparently is
like more than 50% or more more than a
particular percent is not in the movies
and that's bad but if it's just like a
few things here and there totally fine
absolutely acceptable all about board
very legal yeah interesting to hear that
there's an illegal argument at all that
there is a percentage and you would
think that it wouldn't matter but then
you remember that Ron Howard as we shot
80% yeah okay well there are a number of
other little changes during development
in post-production for example the
trailers also had those shots of Loki
flipping these knives that master shot
of Helen the Valkyrie flashbacks slowly
turned towards camera there's that one
line that dr. strange told Thor destiny
has dire plans for you like maybe in
that case they didn't want strange have
too much insight into ass guards fiery
Ragnarok and also ytg said that an early
version of the grandmasters end credits
scene showed him and topaz on earth
undercover like disappearing into a
crowd
also just sign up for those of you
wondering Lady SIF wasn't in this movie
because actress Jamie Alexander was
shooting the show blind spot in New York
during production but at least it
allowed her to survive I think that
maybe she was just like oh send me the
pages oh you know what I can't make it I
saw that I died in one sentence my name
was even I'm really glad that dr.
strange line got cut cuz Thor's response
to it is I have dire plans for destiny
and it's like that wasn't easy
so I'm glad it's not there yeah the the
person who sued drive was mad that that
line wasn't she's starting a revolution
but the third big change in the film
involved a Valkyrie and Thor's past so
when a thorn Valkyrie meet on Sekar
originally they were going to remember
each other from their youth
and there was going to be a flashback to
an 80s version of Asgard that sounds
awesome
yeah uh well whitey described it he said
he won and the characters like in
shoulder pads and mullet yes it'll be
like Earth 80s well so you could
reference the comic book version 2080s
which is something that Thor has always
kind of looked like he still stayed in
the 80s yeah
well the joke was gonna be that Thor was
gonna be this fat teenager and Loki was
gonna be an emo goth kid that's yeah but
and I'm not sure if it was gonna part of
the flashback scene and some people
talking about this but uh or maybe a
different part of the movie but what key
what TZ did apparently shoot a scene
with Valkyrie that confirmed her as a
bisexual person in the character in the
comics as you know it's bisexual we're
gonna see a scene where a woman walks
out of her bedroom but what tt cut it
cuz he said it was just in that moment
just distracting from whatever the
momentum of the scene was what do you
guys think of this whole idea for a
flashback it's amazing you can kind of
see that they did retain like he's got
that like those cuffs you wear when
you're like feeling feelings and like
it's my Chemical Romance yeah I draw
them on me
you know we all went through our faves
yeah it sounds like in all these
examples like what tt want to just have
fun with this and like be more
ridiculous with both like showing Odin
as a homeless person New York and like a
fat version of authority like it was
really thinking like what's the funniest
angle to approach yeah alright let's
let's not do that one time in a movie
isn't just funny saying but the Valkyrie
mentioned actually I do think is
fascinating because there's a question
somebody hit me up on Stardust a hit me
up somewhere else too
they're like wait was Valkyrie a lesbian
did the woman that saved her from being
killed the first time she stopped again
her wife or something and I want to say
just yes I think that's the case but I
can't have loved that it was like so
what not a big deal we're not even gonna
deal with that it's just yeah it
happened to be that just normalize it I
think at the moment we're trying to do
with so many things with diversity and
being inclusive that as soon as you
start going look we're doing it how
great a week you're actually doing more
harm than good and I love how subtle it
is like the fact that you could think
about it a week lair and be like oh wait
North gay that's Kanan that's always
Jane Foster dumped him for a reason yes
wasn't working out make sense yeah well
actually let's order reaction from
Rebecca on Stardust she told us what she
loved the most from Thor Ragnarok yes
went to see it no it's called Thor and
everything but I was totally there for
the Hulk Hulk Hulk Hulk he was fantastic
from the hot tub to bouncing the ball to
pancaking to the giant big monster also
left Korg cork was great I went with a
buddy of mine
this movie was fine Thor Ragnarok was a
fun MCU movie do yourself a favor go see
it it was great or she got to the court
part that was the best sum up of this
movie like pancake the ball the the
falling like at the big monster I loved
it I won't know from you guys she's
throwing Hulk into this as team Hulk
who's your favorite if you had to one of
them had to die oh um hole got some cool
stuff to do I want to see what they're
gonna do with them if you had to kill
one Thor yeah agreed like we've we've
had three movies of Thor like we need to
see Hulk's now I think this would be a
great if they had the legal ability to
give Thor a starring role in its own
movie this would be a good like launch
launching point for him I've said it
before that the Hulk actually has like a
really amazing story and then about you
know mental problems and identity issues
and like that's an awesome story that I
would love to see I'm Israeli and I'm
not allowed to say anyway Thank you
Thank You Rebecca we totally agree and
yeah she answered a question that we
post you guys last week of what was your
what you found funniest from Thor he was
for answers kind of cheese oh she did
overachiever but actually we have some
more responses that we'll get to later
in the video as well as next week's
question that we would love you guys to
answer but if you haven't already click
on our stardust app download link in the
description below and
poster reaction to your favorite movie
or TV show Tagus and a tad new rock
stars so yeah we can feature you like we
did with Rebecca in next week's show
could be it this could be you
but speaking of Thor let's move on to
our weekly trivia question real quick
I had an observation while when I was
thinking about Thor as I do and I
remembered one interesting tidbit about
some people that appeared in this movie
I was like mmm good trivia question so I
think you might be able to get it we'll
see yeah all right but I'm only gonna
give you a very short time to answer
okay all right three actors in thor
ragnarok all appeared together in a
different non MCU property who are the
actors and what is the property oh and
it's not from the MCU but three actors
in this thor ragnarok movie are all
three in the same other non MCU property
it's not a very old one either and who
are they and what is the property three
actors not MCU property were they in the
same scene together in Thor or three
actors that were that story may or may
not have been but that makes it less fun
to make it too easy on you okay so so
while we write our answers down last
week we asked you guys what in Thor
Ragnarok made you laugh the most we
heard a little bit now but also I we
want to hear from three more people who
responded so let's roll some clips
I knew rockstars were asking the
question what's the funniest gag of this
film there's loads and loads to choose
from lots of slapstick and things I'm
gonna go for a slow burner which is
called talking to his little sidekick
meek is it and their sport he's
squatting and stuffs coming out of his
backside super a bit of improv and he's
speculating on what it is and that just
I thought was hilarious as a Kiwi
watching thor ragnarok my funniest thing
was definitely when taka ran in and was
like oh yeah piss off ghost as it's just
a real
can we think to say and we quote it
constantly so I went and saw thor
ragnarok santa twice now in cinema and
every single time I watch it without a
doubt I'll have that you know that laugh
where your chest hurts because you're
trying to be quite sure in a cinema
being respectful you just laugh at
through nose and snots everywhere it's
disgusting but it happened every time I
watched Matt Damon as Loki and Luke
Hemsworth as Thor reference throg just
Oh how's that Star Wars poster on the
back awesome technically I'm not wrong
punishment punishment coming up so yeah
as always the winner of it will be able
to do the goodbyes of the episode and
you can do the goodbyes however you want
and make fun of us and mispronounce our
names and Twitter handles however you
choose the loser as cited by our judges
winners and losers will have to read our
in other news headlines other
need-to-know essential information but
you're gonna have a difficult challenge
at the end of each headline that you
have to read ok yeah and later in the
show we'll also reveal the answer to
this trivia question obviously so more
news okay all right well moving on to
another big story because yeah again
this is the need to know we cover all
kinds of big news in this past week that
you guys need to know about Star Wars
the last Jedi director Rian Johnson will
be launching a new Star Wars trilogy
separate from the current trilogy of
episode 79 it will focus on new
characters from a corner to galaxy that
Star Wars lore has never explored before
earth
so yeah Rian Johnson will write and
direct the first film of the trilogy
also there will be a live-action Star
Wars series that will be released on
Disney's streaming device and well it's
that world
it's the wookie family at the entire
time I'm so excited for it yes all this
Star Wars content the pipeline I wanted
to do around a pitch me here let's pitch
the completely untold Star Wars story
that we are dying to see what type of
characters should take over the
franchise what corner of the galaxy do
we need to explore and like what kind of
tone should this new movie trilogy and
TV series have I want to see not the Old
Republic okay never being explored
because technically this hasn't been
touched with in Canon but it is in the
expanded universe now legends instead of
going which corner of the galaxy let's
go back in time because the galaxy has
been around for a long long time and the
Old Republic was between I think five
and twenty five thousand years before
the events of the new hope and this is
where it wasn't the rule with that long
yeah yeah and there were a lot of Jedi
and a lot of seers and it was like I
think I've mentioned this before is like
the x-men opening crawl with this
cartoon where they just do do do it's
like that bajillion see it's right and
it's not the rule of two so it's not
trying to you know kill and find that
you're either they apprentice or the
master it is two armies that have very
very different abilities that are going
head-to-head now in particularly in
nights ago Republic it focuses around
the the safe side of things where it's
particularly two again the the master
and the apprentice I don't necessarily
know if I need that but I love this
space and the world have-nots the Oh
Republic you haven't played the game I
think this is a video game apart from
Ocarina
that I played the most and it's
available on everything iPad MacBook and
everything says no excuse but we need
this again and I want to say it as if it
was like x-men where it's two sides but
there's a lot there and it's just Jedi
and Sith powers galore especially if
they did take the x-men example or and
early on you could explore the the
reason why the Sith are the way they are
instead of just like blanket evil yes
yeah yeah and that's and I love that
Disney is no longer saying it's good and
evil it's lights out in the dark side
and that is such a great area I'm coming
please get great Jedi's but anyway
that's right yes but I think that that's
so worth exploring so I pitched just
like a number of times before actually
but I actually am very passionate about
technology and how it can be so much
more than we know so I want a droid
trilogy but I want droids of all kinds I
want them to be on their own planet
these are droids that have been outcast
it's kind of like an island of misfit
toys kind of thing but the droids and
they have a hierarchy and they have
droids that are kind of like worker
droids in their lower class and then
they have like more like you know
language or ever that are of a higher
class right yeah and then specifically
the EU are playing with a little bit of
like in Star Wars the droids I mean look
at c-3po look at k2i so these are people
so it is a little bit of the themes of
like Blade Runner or whatever where are
the limits of humanity and not are you
had your time humans they're more human
than we are well and I think that you
know there's a reason why we react so
strongly to two animals getting hurt or
something is because these things have
like a lot that could be explored and
essentially some version of a soul
potentially I mean how many movies about
robots have gone down that path like do
I have a soul so I want to see that but
also throwing the idea for sensitive
robots article uh droids I and you could
have like oh it's flaring up but I still
think there's so much to do with droids
because and I'll again double down on
this I Kate to us I was the best
character in rogue one
yeah he's the only one that you felt
anything when he died
for sure it's something this is a bit of
a like a droid story Star Wars a droid
story right like oh so like a Toy Story
version move detroit's like they have
their own lives and I mean that sounds
like a cute version of what I'm saying
I'm saying like Pixar animated like
Bicentennial man I love that movie but
think about this for a second roughly
chopping my noggin see if I can remember
what she said in my ear what about a
smuggler story just picture this first
thing no just like following around I'm
following following the story of a han
Solo type of gang you know in the past
your deal with bounty hunters you're
gonna be dealing with maybe drugs
surprise by smuggling information you're
gonna go as me parsecs as you can get to
in a three movies look at even other
people I've got ideas for this but
honestly that I agree with Molly no she
gave me the idea I think that would be
really fun because yeah you watch the
Star Wars movies for me again from the
outside of not being a full nerd you you
want the you want the force you want the
lightsabers you want the droids but
there is something special about trying
to tell a more normal story or like when
you have society like this where like
hierarchies like pop up really fast
again there might be more to their
society that I don't know about but I
think it would be really interesting to
see how like somebody would try to be
successful in this galaxy without you
know having to have these special
abilities because it seems like
immediately you have the upper hand in
every single way just bring back Firefly
actually just do fired that's a TV show
is gonna pitch his Firefly but with
actually rogue one like the premise of
it was they didn't all you know the end
of the movie but that idea of a team
doing spy stuff you could make a very
long series with that you can make a
really long series and Disney will just
funnel money into that yeah Mison
Bothans this time maybe yeah I mean I
totally agree my my pitches are centered
on that idea too because I think my
favorite part of the Star Wars movies
has been the war element and I like that
idea when rogue one
initially was like brought up to us as
this idea for a movie yeah I would love
to see just like the millet the grounded
military approach as much as I love the
whole force mythology and and how like
little little actions and decisions can
have huge effects like I like that whole
theme but yeah I wanted to see what the
just a foot soldier does and I think
rogue one kind of got there it just
narrative Lee had some issues that
prevented it from being that but my idea
for a trilogy would center around like
you know so after World War two ended
you know how there was that lone
Japanese soldier on an island somewhere
in the Pacific who like decades later
didn't know the war you know it didn't
end until the 70s yeah and yeah we was
brought back to Japan and got this
hero's welcome like what a loyal
patriotic soldier who just like stood
his post for decades
I would love this Star Wars equivalent
of that just seeing some some
stormtroopers there planets like there
the war should have ended for like
another hundred years like some plants
cuz they just didn't know they didn't
have communication if they have to like
transfer by hand a drive with the Death
Star plans they don't have the right
yeah the regional governors still
maintain control over their star systems
but I would love to see just a small
like I I mean even though if it's a
trilogy you'd have to bring another B
plots and other narratives in there but
I would love if that's the focus of just
this one Empire soldier who's still
trying to maintain his post okay well
let's move on to another story another
new story that you need to know about
this week okay we just learned that
Niantic neon technic Niantic the gaming
company behind Pokemon go is launching a
Harry Potter AR game it is called Harry
Potter wizards unite now according to
Niantic Niantic by exploring real world
neighborhoods and cities across the
globe I'm reading their copy here
players will go on adventures learn and
cast spells discover mysterious
artifacts and encounter legendary beasts
and where to find them and iconic
characters now I thought to be
interesting for us to look at this by
the numbers with this week's number
being 45 million the number number was
by the way the peak number of daily
active users that Pokemon go read daily
daily active users in July 2016
of course dropped down to five million
daily active users as of last April I
was doing yeah I did but then I forgot
my login and I just yeah this was the
number of videos we made about it
I did do what I did a little trip in
Europe but I did catch a mr. mind when I
was there a friend of ours asked if I
could get it for their son as a present
and you charged how much in Japan I
really liked that Pokemon when I was a
kid anyways night will reach these kind
of numbers 45 words alive yeah you have
to compare where the franchise was
before the game and I think Pokemon even
though it has a very very hardcore
audience like the movies have kind of
simmered down a little bit I think it
peaked like as a franchise for me I was
only gen 1 like I only really lost a gen
1 I I still played all the games but my
interest I was like I'm getting older no
I can't I love it I love the world and I
missed movies and I cried I sobbed
hysterically when I finished the last
book and then finished the last movie
because it was over so to immerse me
into that world and then it's also got
the you know the success of Pokemon
backing that it's like you were loved
that so much some people show realize
that well 40 million people realize that
it didn't have long play value right but
they were still got many people there
I'm so about it and I'm a Gryffindor by
the way uh-huh oh we took the test yeah
my counterpart I do agree with mod that
like I think Harry Potter is actually
more of an active burning in people's
hearts right now at this moment and
Pokemon felt like it was a reactivation
yea wakening but my counterpoint to that
the concept of Pokemon you know you want
to go out and be a master and you want
to collect Pokemon you want to do
exactly what the game was designed to do
and I think we had this conversation
when we heard that they were doing a
Harry Potter version but like what we
had to like think like what could they
do fantastic beasts yeah yeah we had to
like hunt in our head to figure out what
the connection could be that would make
it this AR game and the fact that that
is not easy and not at the front of your
brain makes me think that there isn't
enough connection to like a desire to
want to be a wizard I I think a game
about being a wizard and that's the only
thing you're doing that obviously has
way more potential to fantasy there was
a there was a report that came out like
this week or last talking about that
Pokemon is one of or it's in like the
top like five most successful franchises
that's ever existed it's just like
because it and also if you guys like
think about it it doesn't have a long
retention of fans fans kind of like boot
out when they get like 15 something or
they pick it back up in college to play
because that's really popular for
college kids but they constantly get new
kids to like play it because they pump
out a new game every like three five
years and they have a TV show that the
TV show will end and they'll me they
make two more and like it constantly is
getting at least the younger audience so
like that's a little different from
Harry Potter which still has really
dedicated fans even though there isn't
any new content besides fantastic beasts
coming out so I don't think you're gonna
get anywhere near the 45 million yeah
maybe initially but it won't I don't I
really don't see it getting that kind of
number yeah this the difference I think
for me is like Pokemon go as someone who
like yeah we played Pokemon the version
of Pokemon go as an AR game is almost
like wish fulfillment like I remember
playing red and being like man I wish
like a Pikachu just walk out of the
bushes right now so whimsical Knight
yeah stole a lot of cats the super
charging with electricity and I yeah I
think and then they made that like viral
video that came out that a lot people
saying that like they took the idea for
Pokemon go from that video of like
wouldn't it be great if this existed
whereas with Harry Potter I think the
the wish fulfillment was like man I wish
there was like a
Diagon Alley I wish there was a real
Hogwarts that I could go to and arguably
the universal parks in Orlando and right
down the street from I created these for
us so like as like a kid if you're
reading the books there is a Hogwarts
you could go to you just pay Universal
whatever is the day right to go there so
there is a version of that that exists I
don't know how much more I mean I'll
probably play this air game I'm super
excited about it and I think the
difference might be fantastic be smarter
because that did kind of restart the
movie franchise and there is an element
of like these you know magical beasts
have scattered all over our world and we
have to go find them now maybe there
might be some angle there that and what
hotter more get cuz Pottermore came out
after the movies didn't it sounds about
right and it still got like a crazy and
it wasn't much content on that you just
got sorted into a house you got
allocated a wand and then they made a
new school as well ill the morni but as
far as like the actual content it was
mainly written pieces you know acting as
a glossary almost but I wasn't a huge
Harry Potter fan
even though who doesn't love a Harry
Potter movie but I even checked out that
website multiple times so it's like it's
gonna get numbers initially when I
launches I just don't know if it can
sorry
just when you walked outside during
Pokemon go season I mean it was like
overpopulation suddenly where
everybody's been there hiding I feel
like we're thinking that they're just
going to change they keep the exact
schematics yeah and I think they're
going to have to completely pivot the
design and offer something very very
different from Pokemon go I think that
AR is probably the only thing that will
stay the same but everything else like
they're gonna they're gonna have to
completely change it because you can't
just yeah switch one out for the other
successfully it could be really cool it
could be like you know you're walking
around your neighborhood or downtown
wherever you live and they're able to
like geotag these locations this know
this is actually the secret home of
such-and-such wizard or there's a
Dementor behind this trashcan or
something like that other things the
idea of AR and now you are suddenly
privy to a magical world that is among
put a phone in front of it and you it a
I put on the house colors that people
would register that unveil your actual
house colors Oh member one Pokemon go
made that little bracelet and in no one
no one bought it it was that button he
was supposed to like vibrate or
something when the Pokemon was in the
way you know I didn't get I didn't
wanted I did want it really bad but then
I realized it didn't do anything just
Ranger battery really really fast but if
it hadn't like another like what do you
call those what do you call those
accessory but there's like another a
peripheral it had a peripheral like that
that I think that could also on
peripheral yeah yeah like or something
time Turner yeah yeah I always wanted
one of those we all right well moving on
to another big news story from this week
earliest week we heard rumors that
Disney was in talks to purchase Fox 2020
first Century Fox's film and TV
properties which would finally allow all
the Marvel Studios characters of course
the Avengers guardians the galaxy etc to
appear in movies with the x-men Deadpool
and the Fantastic Four like it these
talks are dead the deal isn't happening
it would be a little crazy by the way
because that would put Disney in control
of 40% of all of our entertainment take
it take it
but guys guys what if what if we lived
an alternate timeline alternate timeline
where these properties we're all part of
the same universe I think we should
discuss the film and TV landscape what
it would look like if the Avengers and
x-men could you know hang out together
like what movies that we've seen before
what movies would be different
what comic addict adaptations would be
possible in this hypothetical and in
this hypothetical world did they already
make Civil War yeah let's assume they
have already made Civil War and it's
like right now that yeah it's 2017 this
deal does happen I still say remake a
new version of Civil War call it
whatever we want but do civil war with
all of these characters because that's I
mean the comic actually is not it's not
the best but it it's
the team ups that happen across he's
like these people that you never think
would get together and then the causes
of civil wars also characters you never
think would matter
and then the especially the part that
frustrated me the most about the movie
even though I similar was a great movie
obviously if you read the comic my
favorite part is that the idea of going
underground and having to have you know
this whole other Avengers team that
operates essentially through sewers and
stuff like that was fascinating to me
and it's a whole thing that they
couldn't do because it just wasn't
enough characters yeah man if they could
just do a version of so you could do
that as a trilogy or you could do it as
like a six-part series on your new
streaming service Disney like that would
be perfect for it like an hour long
because isn't it like multi-part
chapters in the comic story every single
adjacent comic had to deal with similar
storylines to I think the only that you
could do it now and you pull the same
thing doctor change was it was like no
Wizards have been here the whole time or
sorry sorcerers because someone's gonna
be like that in the comments uh but like
they're like we're here the whole time
but we just manipulate time and when you
spells and you can't see us here we're
not here an x-men it's just like a same
thing basically we just have this big
exactly and then you go in like and then
like you get classic movie you get like
the normal like kid like wandering in
and all the sudden he stumbles onto
Xavier school and I call the x-men are
there and they're younger they you keep
in spider-man's age but you have some of
the older ones yeah rebooted with all
new actors yep
cuz I did not like the ones they used in
Apocalypse get new ones please or any
any of the actors can't like not even
Hugh Jackman different timeline we've
already discussed how could it be in
Thor if we saw an 80s side of it all
it's the same thing with this how cool
it'd be if we started and we had the
older characters young again like a
young star said we did young storm and
then see exactly that's the thing I
wasn't a big fan of that but we're also
talking about this idealized version
where the reason I said give it to
Disney give it to Disney is because
Disney does mail it yeah you know so
they could do young I mean look at
spider-man spider-man is such a good
movie
I think they nail it but they don't
always allow for I think diversity of
types of story like would Disney have
allowed low
Ogin or Deadpool these are rated edge
know what Brooklyn is trying to be at
least but it's not our rate it I think
murdered a lot of people in that they
just want violent about it yeah if it
doesn't appeal to the four quadrants as
they say within the industry Disney
usually shied away from it or they'll
give it to one of the other production
companies that they own like touchstone
or something to pursue that like darker
type of content people say that though
but Wolverines a violent character it's
not like they have another character on
there that is as violent as him and if
they had him you kind of have to and it
would be dumb of Disney to not like lean
into Deadpool's also raunchy humor and
fourth wall breaking and like he's
hanging out with strippers and like he's
drugs and like he's just getting blown
apart like it's he's everything yeah you
have to lean into that so Disney could
lean into that because like they allow
them to say pardon my french [ __ ] every
once in a while in a Marvel movie they
get it let's find out next week I mean
Punisher but Fantastic Four sorry you
want to say I go I've been talking about
no I listened but Fantastic Four would
be an amazing I think it would be a
really good model for a TV series yeah
but then I'm like oh wait the thing
never mind and Johnny Storm it's like
you could make Jenny Storm because
you're just getting far away but it's
like yeah I'm watching humans I'm
getting a hint no stop trying with
Inhumans yeah I think if you are going
to introduce them in the most successful
way I see your Civil War but I raise you
one the Infinity Wars it's probably
gonna be an easier way to introduce just
so many more characters because it's not
it's the universe and so that's where
like a lot of things could come out of
the Woodworks more successfully and then
of course you're right you deal with the
space-time continuum and everything is
possible yeah yeah punch a little hole
through reality and then you like merge
some realities there like now the
immunes have always been here Inhumans
never never
except for lockjaw cuz put him in a
movie was real cute I would love a I
mean as much as I loved Logan which did
take a lot from the comic old man Logan
like we didn't really see a true at it
station of old man Logan which is even
more violent and features like that as a
slumlord and goes on a road trip my
skull isn't it is that the in spoilers
for old man Logan but somebody killed
giant man when he was still giant and
like he disintegrated and there's so
many crazy like I would love like a
Tarantino Robert Rodriguez version of
that sort yeah well let's move on to our
next news story okay so Justice League
less than a week away guys we are
learning some final interesting details
from a recent full cast press conference
and other media appearances along some
early reviews on Twitter from people who
somehow have seen it I don't know how I
had some friends so I'm gonna not even
joking if you know who I need to email
yeah so that we get to see some movies
early we would really appreciate that I
will send you an Xbox we're gonna break
down all the key final info you need to
know we went through all this stuff and
we're distilling just the need-to-know
information here okay so everyone in the
cast sounds super intent on making us
believe that Superman is indeed dead
including Henry Cavill now I guess this
could just because it is super moon
returning and is one of the biggest
questions that they're all getting
ologists Jon Snow rolls yes yes he said
it's not like to me like they've got
some specific talking points though from
this studio to just set expectations so
yeah don't look at what happened okay so
Ezra Miller went to detail about the
Flash's relationship with the speedforce
water is theorizing about this
phenomenon it's gonna be a big part
about his characters arc setting up his
movie
we Sam is incredulous already that he's
the better part of the movie really
relief he was pretty funny in the clips
I've seen so far and I've heard a lot of
good things about cyborg but we'll get
there yeah thanks some more information
gal gadot confirmed that the name a
Wonder Woman was given to Diana by the
people whom she saved probably referring
to the people in the town of Belle to
remember from the one that we saw her
liberate that town
who gave her her logo and everyone
else's logo where did that suit come
from she has a marketing department
okay so there's also been some mixed
messages about the tone of the movie
like many of the cast members are
describing the movie as about hope but
Henry Cavill said that right that's he
said that calling the movie light would
be an injustice while he's playing the
game holding it yeah some more
information cavil wouldn't give us more
information about that cryptic black
Superman s costume that he posted on
social media but he did say that if
Clark Kent were to return the rebirth
comets are comics are a good inspiration
now though in those that's Clark has a
different relation with Lois he has a
son so is just gonna interesting weird
that character and rebirth has like 90
years ago story behind him yes sure the
cast also talked about some scenes that
were deleted from the film including one
where the flash Barry Helen eats a ton
of hamburgers I mean super fast it's
completely fly there's also an emotional
reunion between cyborg and his mother
and finally some early reviews from
these lucky bastards on Twitter have
described the film as fun praising the
character development chemistry of the
Justice League team members but they had
mixed feelings about the story in the
thin the villain which they kinda script
is like CGI
it's like stop stop taking us out of the
world when we have so close to giving a
[ __ ] right yeah so based on all this
information what do you guys think are
you excited for Justice League next week
or less stay right here just stay this
is the lane you stay and just stay here
never Wonder Woman and I was ever
everybody was surprised by Wonder Woman
and not not because of don't read into
that it's just we have based on history
this movie was looking like it was gonna
be really bad also like everyone pointed
out before that movie came out the
advertising like advertising just
disappeared for like a month and no one
was talking about the movie so with this
just go middle road yeah I like it you
like protecting our hearts I feel really
good add words like heartbroken us on
you just go do you keep your head down
well actually Phillip posted a reaction
about the the review embargo Phillips
can give some details on that on Justice
League
until 16 hours before the movie comes
out of theaters usually not a good sign
yeah yeah I mean it's kind of what we're
saying but it's like anytime I see a
review embargo that goes into the well
into the week of the movie that comes
Blade Runner did that Blade Runner was
great might just be a Warner Brothers
thing it was the day before it sunk
Dunkirk as well both of them is try
another thing of the strictest review
embargoes they couldn't even say certain
basic first act plot information about
blade strategic for movies bad they're
just gonna go ahead and put an embargo
across all movies and now it's like hey
you know you can't tell yeah it's like
putting the the cup under the ball well
another positive thing that we have seen
some of the reviews is that
there is someone to relate or at least
the caste is trying to put this out
there of like there's all the characters
are so well defined that there is
someone you might be able to relate to
in this movie so we're gonna make this
our Stardust question for you guys yeah
those robots out there since its
dropping next week for the next episode
of the neato you saw our last week we
asked to post up here for next week we
want to ask you what Justice League
member do you mostly I do do you
identify with the most right I'll be the
corpse of Superman I've relate the most
with him des lying there in this little
box right yeah so what we'd like you to
do is yeah post your reaction this week
and tag us at new rock stars and yes we
will feed you we're gonna be reviewing
everything we liked things that we had
gripes with Justice League when we end
up seeing it next week that will be next
week's need to know topics so we will
feature your reaction in the video so
just tag us and that new rock stars but
let's move on to our and okay so our our
next big story also Disney related
Disney was butting heads with the media
Basket week
so last week Disney banned the LA Times
from advanced screenings of its movies
including guys all Star Wars Marvel
Pixar properties every Disney owns so
much now the reason was that the LA
Times published a story that criticized
Disney's privileged business
relationship with the city of Anaheim
California that's where Disneyland is
now after Disney announced this
punishing ban on the LA Times a number
of other media outlets critics
organizations celebrities and youtubers
like us denounced this ban and stood
with the LA Times boycotting Disney
films until Disney agreed to drop the
ban which they did so I'm if you guys
don't mind I'm gonna go on a quick
little rant might be a bit of an
unpopular opinion on some things but it
feel free to disagree okay I don't want
to wade too deep into the politics of
this though if you're interested in
local government and in balance tax
incentives that LA Times article is
fascinating but really I just think we
learned a valuable lesson this week on
the power of the Walt Disney Corporation
and our culture and whether or not
that's a good thing and where that where
the restraints might need to come in
I love Disney I want to say that we they
were the primary creative influence on
me as a young storyteller and now I
really love that they're in control of
Star Wars and Marvel I think in many
ways that has made those brands even
better as we've been saying this episode
and yeah I love the Disney parks I get
that Disney Land if you look at the
history of it more or less created the
city feel free to disagree but when
Disney starts flexing its commercial
might to try to silence what I think is
good quality journalism at the same time
we hear these rumors of the company
acquiring Fox expanding to nearly half
of all entertainment that we consume it
just starts make me feel a little scared
a little like like two can fire you know
like the more a powerful company becomes
the more powerful company becomes it
starts to feel above public scrutiny
that just it's natural for human nature
to go that way and I think we already
have enough problems with people
distrust in the media nowadays guys
right so I think on many levels I'm a
little relieved to hear that Disney
those Fox negotiations aren't happening
partly because I just don't think Disney
ever would have allowed r-rated Deadpool
irlo gonna get made but also I just
don't need one big powerful company
controlling everything I can see yeah I
don't know that's just me III think mass
media consolidation and the singularity
is still 11 10 years away so let's just
enjoy as many different types of
storytellers as we can it's already too
late Erik you know have a tantrum in a
very very public way because you didn't
like what was talked about you yes you
know and then to then punish and to
censor in a way one particular media
outlet I think it's great though that
the rest of the media was standing up to
this because it wasn't it's it's not
playing by the rules I can it sucks when
this happens we have they're putting
more highlight I read this article
because of what went down why was it
banned I was more interested in knowing
about the story and did you know that
the Disney park their car parks what do
you guys call them the parks yep they're
owned by the city of Anaheim and they
rented to Disney for $1 and what is it
the money that that makes thirty million
dollars in revenue on an average year
Wow anyway this is kind of interesting
stuff that I learned because they banned
it hahaha and it ya notice nothing to do
if you want it didn't buried don't point
going we don't like this no you buy out
the company Disney bye
like Disney couldn't buy the LA Times no
one's reading newspapers alright the way
that the media stepped up to recognize
this was so there was I think so many
different film festivals were taking
Disney out of the running
yeah winning any of the awards yeah
because I was like you're not playing
yeah I'm sorry I was just agreeing like
oh yeah remember that - yeah mm-hmm I
Disney feeling I don't want to be if you
will give me these advanced screenings I
will send you an Xbox early it would
make my life a lot easier not afford
that new rock stars okay let's move on
to our need to know like okay so these
are I'm gonna hit the three of you guys
with rapid-fire off-the-cuff questions
that you have to answer you guys gave -
yeah we asked you guys earlier to tweet
these to us I'm just reading them off of
the thread right now but make sure to
tweet us next Friday so that we have
more questions to bombard us ourselves
with okay so here we
okay we'll start with my favorite things
to eat / drink while binging that's from
at nerd soda 140 at least 5 opt a
hundred percent M&M peanuts only Tim
Tams there's a new pineapple flavor is
amazing I like to dip dip and chip like
a cracker with Philadelphia cheese
that's too lightning shorty shorts a
past Marvel movie or TV character you'd
like to see brought back and infinity
war reintroduced or time-travel it's
from at WT underscore Quicksilver that's
good that's a good short one twice as
thick so I can't I can't hear you for
you ok do you think they'll ever give
Green Lantern a second chance no if so
do you think they'll do how Jordan or
Jon Stewart or possibly Kyle Rayner al
Jordan because he makes the most money
he's the original one and they're doing
the Green Lantern Corps movie it's a
buddy cop movie with Jon Stewart how
Jordan yet Simon Baz and Jessica Cruise
but they're gonna go with the most
popular one it's Hal Jordan and it's
already happening it's already happening
and they ready confirmed it's Hal Jordan
and Jon Stewart because Jon Stewart
deserves as he's been doing for a long
time yeah but two things you like to
binge eat peanut butter M&M peanut
butter broccoli Trader Joe's
Scandinavian swimmers that's all like
three bags at a time but you already got
a bad candy and then you got the
knockoff of the mag ship in from Norway
maude lightning chitron what do you
think of the snazzy new Doctor Who
outfit from ad Joshua John banks it's a
lot of fun it's kind of going back to
the Tom Baker feel we think the stripes
and I'm loving the overalls I just don't
she needs all the help she can get you
know I love it she's not overtly
sexualized in any particular way so I'm
all about it
Philip and this might be a little hard
to do quickly but do you think the night
king can resurrect a rotisserie chicken
technically the chicken corpse was
exposed to fire but it's not completely
burned yeah no of course it can it's
just gonna roll like around because it
has no little chicken feet and they've
already shown that you can a chicken
will run around without a head even if
it's alive without the night king
involved so yes Sam least favorite
Justice League member Oh actually
persimmon I mean based on the claim yeah
because I haven't seen the movie that's
making hard on him yeah no just the
movie I mean based on history no I
actually
Aquaman I mean I'm excited to see him
Jason I'm always gonna be great but
normal comic one man so many Aquaman
fans they're some of the meanest fans
they will fight to the death for Aquaman
yeah Aquaman tried and there was one for
me here how long do you think you can go
in an unedited breakdown so like those
of you who watch our Walking Dead
breakdowns no I'm doing them all live to
tape and I'm doing them on one take I'm
doing a killer job you love them don't
you and uh yeah longest one I go 15
minutes I think that might've been her
longest one was around 15 minutes guys
it's really hard and I and I screw up a
lot of words but like you know I make up
for it with this charm this guy screws
up more words than you do but you're
just not around for we're thinking about
releasing
because we got to do something with
these hours of footage every video
working real take a look at what we got
in the pipeline for things coming out in
the next seven days or so okay so
obviously next week will be the premiere
of Justice League will spend next week's
need-to-know reviewing the film but it's
also we confirm that there will be two
end credits scenes we'll have a separate
video breaking down those and yeah I'll
be doing a Walking Dead episode four
titled some guy and like seeing right
there episode six
yeah and he's actually amazing he's so
he's so good he sneezes face off oh
sorry got punched in the mouth yeah it's
good to go watch it we got a story I've
got we've got two really special videos
coming out this week that I'm really
excited for you guys see I can't tell
you exactly what they are yet but
they're going to be out very soon just a
few days after you watches they're both
Star Wars related but the movies one is
about Star Wars Battlefront which I know
you're gonna talk about in a second but
we're gonna put together a real cool
thing for those of you that are really
interested in the campaign and the story
of what new things have been added to
the Star Wars universe in battlefront 2
and then the other thing is going to be
about a real cool without giving it away
I'll just say the fighting styles within
Star Wars and I'll say that there was a
professional swordsman here and he hurt
Eric well he life flashed before my eyes
it's several and that video is coming
next does it sound like a professional
event the window luckily there's a
mattress truck down below so in looking
ahead beyond next week there we have a
breakdown of the Justice League that we
will be doing in the following week and
I know those of you Game of Thrones fans
of our rewatched series we have
an episode of brick of episode 4 a
breakdown of episode 4 coming
that's a cripples bastards and broken
things from season 1 it's a really great
up so that found a lot of fun
connections that we miss it for some
around so it's stay tuned for that but
let's move on to our it's time now for
our 15-second shoutout 15 seconds -
shout out plug or ramble about whatever
we want Sam why don't you start well
thank you so much I say that everyone
should finish this video then go run out
and watch the florida project it's a
Shaun Baker I believe is the director it
just follows the life of yes stars
Willem Dafoe and this amazing actress
I'm blanking on a name because I think
this is might be your first or second
movie but it just captures the the true
essence of childhood and like I don't
think these kids actually have any lines
they're just given like hey you should
do this hey you should do this and these
kids are acting just like kids yeah it
is so heartwarming and I think it's the
best role Willem Dafoe's had in years
because I can only think of I can't
think of like Wes Anderson stuff and him
as Green Goblin and then that one
Finding Nemo thing that's all he's ever
been in he's just that famous from the
yeah I love Florida poacher and we grew
up in Florida so it's like it was just
like a slice okay the movie I watch it's
not as heartwarming at all it's a
terrifying it's called the killing of a
sacred deer it's a lobster it's got a
Nicole Kidman this amazing role but yeah
it's a very unsettling a kind of like
revenge tale I don't want to say too
much about it but it felt very much like
The Shining so if you love Kubrick and
he loved the shining this is a good
movie for you but yeah do not it's not a
good date movie everyone who I was in
the ArcLight movie theater with was like
squirming and like just confused but
it's super like a lot of subtle
symbolism in there that I'm like I
didn't totally process this movie yet I
gotta go watch it like that subtle
symbolism where it's like why is her
face bleeding through every pore like
weird there is some very disturbing
violence that I honestly had to look at
the floor for like a good 10 seconds but
it's not like it's not like Aronofsky's
mother if you saw it where it's just
like it's beating us over the head with
the symbolism it's very subtle and very
much like The Shining in a good way same
guy did the lobster yes but send to us
both of us what your thoughts are on
this movie because I saw it as well
you know reactions that one startup
feature some 15 seconds yeah we're not
sticking to that we're doing great
I'll keep my nice and short because I
yeah if this videos like 12 seconds long
so I'm just gonna talk for as long as
videos it's called a qbo and it's a
laser burning device that you can burn
with a laser into anything
no you definitely are you can definitely
use it to hurt people but you can also
use it to help people if you're a good
person no I think it's so cool to just
like like laser etch into like wood or
laser etch into like leather or
something is that what you only was like
three seconds you're gonna come in with
a bunch of leather now aren't you it all
has like this like poor design that I
made myself and then my skin is burned
underneath because I didn't take the
jacket off yeah I mean they have to sit
stuff like 25 minutes but yeah so kids
if you want to go blind in one eye
[Music]
cutter yeah the creepy crawlers up in
like anything that could use to create
or destroy a single-player campaign I
only got to play multiplayer really to
holding I did the campaign for nine and
a half hours straight
two days there's a lot of playing so
real quick I you don't know this I saw
footage of the multiplayer whatever and
I saw how you performed in it and
whether or not you got killed a lot or
killed people a lot not sure I did i
sorry because you were playing this geek
bomb and somebody somebody posted their
videos someone else was playing game
journalists right professional game is
like IGN Brazil like all the
international big game you doing I was
against I want a few thank you here is
this I was in the top but we lost
overall because I was the best out of my
group which said something but what I
wanted to talk about is that if you
played the first game you
like a lot was lacking they definitely
listened to you and there is a lot more
I think there's five different ways to
play multiplayer a lot like this like
nine games and one and it's like you can
play it so many different ways you can
do local co-op
you can go online you can play by
yourself offline as well as you don't
even have to go online and then there's
the story you play a single-player
campaign which is what I was interested
in learning because it lacked in the
first game we didn't exist yeah there
was nothing and then this one it's huge
there's so much going on in this it's
like anyway I'm doing a video on the
multiplayer side of things I think
you're taking on the campaign exactly so
we're covering basically the entire game
because your video will be on geek bomba
yep
well finally let's return to the trivia
question that we asked so the person
that wins will take care of our Twitter
handles in the end and guys you gotta
remember to make fools of us
just really let us have it let us know
how you really feel about so if you
don't have to use our real names as you
do and the loser is going to have to
give you everything else you need to
know about what happened in the news
this week but every headline they read
they're gonna have to tag it with just
such a good joke that they just came up
with right on the spot right there about
that headline I can sense the energy
that mods like I want to step up to that
challenge my panic
so the question it was three actors in
Thor Ragnarok all appeared together in a
different non MCU property who are the
three actors and what is the property so
the yeah so Eric thinks that no wait
sorry I'm wrong this this is mod I'm
answering this question on behalf of the
Internet this is a mod and the
Internet's answer this is why we have
IMDB and then a drawing of Eric
long hair yeah I get that right answer
you know feels like it's gonna be
considered the wrong answer and then
this is Sam saying that it's hunt for
the wilderness to covert Edie's previous
film before this one and it would
include taiko himself Sam Neill and
henchwoman
I don't remember her now remind me
han-shan went to Jeff Goldblum
so though this is also your oh hold on
do we do it eric says sam neill rachel
house i think that's their name question
mark this is why we have IMDB and Taika
Waititi hunt for the wilderquest other
people usually prepare because there's
probably more than one right answer to
this so even though that probably right
I would say none of you are right
because the one I'm thinking of and you
had to be in my head it was the
Hemsworth right yeah and the scene with
Sam Neill right he was playing Thor in
the mock right yeah it was
what's her name Valkyries Thomson what
was the question
movie property checked so judges who got
the closest Erik because he had an eight
his name's right today right rich woman
yeah no I knew the okay for this I mean
it's gonna be Maude
it's like turning in the textbook at an
exam I can't do that
[Music]
you don't get it the hamsters in the
book I spent like five minutes saying
how Disney wasn't playing by the rules
and now I'm going what would take the
number of videos that we make that could
be answered by this is what we have IMDB
we just can't I guess here we go zingers
already of the week that people need to
know about cool well the Shazam movie
they cast actor angel is new channels
and eMac to play Billy Batson the boy
who transforms into Zam who's gonna be
played by Zack Levi uh-huh and here's
[Music]
Jay Dana Jamison JK Evan Rachel Wood
tweeted that the show's second season
would return in spring spring in it but
I can't so I've just explained the joke
instead and I'm gonna leave it up
that doesn't look like anything to me
time with these things Evan Rachel Wood
but didn't like the other joke better
how do you laugh more than all of us
combined
despite fan speculation Luke Skywalker
will not turn to the dark side in the
last Jedi I just went straight to
something real smutty oxide but it could
happen in the parody version I mean you
could say the dirty thing okay not going
to the dark spot alright
okay so victory lap guys watching this
sim basher more like oh we're all
splitting the bill but I got Sam no cash
or Phillip when you asked his opinion on
things no lean to either side is empty
suit I write jokes to the Friars Club
the name for take why are you doing this
year
it's really hurting my I'm gonna hurt
and then also wanna tank
Maude Garrett more like oh good Karen
alright drop you I want fan art for tank
okay remember to hit us up with those
responses on our starters question what
Justice League member do you identify
with the most and why is that one Roman
if you're female and tag us in your tag
us at new records in your Stardust
reaction so that we can see and we might
feature it in next week's episode and of
course with all our videos comment down
below this is a conversation we want to
hear what you guys think on all these
topics and so you can tell us what kind
of topics you want us to see us cover
and tweet us at new rock stars using the
hashtag need-to-know like this video
share it around subscribe to new rock
stars for all of our deep dives and the
stuff that you love guys see you next
week thank you thank you
[Music]